the war in Ukraine reaches the
nine-month Milestone this week at the
beginning of the war of course very few
people believe that the country could
hold out against a much stronger Russian
army could hold out for this long
however Cutting Edge technology like
drones in particular has helped
ukrainians Ukraine's military on the
battlefield Chris livesay met with a
reconnaissance unit on the front lines
for a rare look at how drones are being
used
if this is a war between David and
Goliath then this is David's sling
vastly outnumbered and outgunned by
Russia Ukraine has assembled an army of
drones they're precise and Nimble just
like the crack team that literally
pulled us through the mud to their
secret launch site I have already got
few calls asking what sector are we
going to cover today with our
reconnaissance because everyone is
interested to get some information and
they're counting on you
counting on them to fly over enemy lines
as the eyes of the artillery you locate
the Target and then they decide if and
when they're going to strike yeah
exactly exactly I would say that this
war is a drone War a war Russia is
fighting dirty firing self-destructing
drones into populated areas Ukraine
responded by sea penetrating deep into
Russia's port in Crimea with boat drones
Underdog victories often aided by
volunteers like our escort Army SOS it
was out motivated people I don't think
we would have any success to me that
seems like the one resource that has
been so underestimated in Ukraine
motivation yeah it has been
underestimated by Putin I believe
underestimated by Putin even the rest of
the world but never by Ukraine
for CBS mornings Chris livesay on the
front line in eastern Ukraine